Çeviri: Melis Meyer-Gümüs
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Hoş geldiniz, her şeyden önce.
Yıllar sonra bir 23 Nisan'da
böyle bir sunum yapacağımı söyleseler
inanmazdım herhâlde.
O yüzden saçlarımı ördürttüm.
Raunta çıkıyormuş gibi.
Bana ilk söyledikleri zaman
gidilmeyen yol diye,
aslında yolculuğumdan bahsetmem
gerektiğini anlamıştım.
Ama biraz daha düşününce, aslında
benim yolculuğum biraz daha farklıydı.
Çünkü başkalarına göre gidilmeyen yol,
benim ilk gittiğim yol,
gidilmemesi gereken bir yoldu.
Yıllarca beni bu konuda uyardılar,
"yapma"
"aç kalırsın"
"işsiz kalırsın"
"kimsesiz kalırsın"
"bu bacaklarla mı kadın olacaksın".
Bunun gibi uyarılara rağmen
ilk önce gidilmeyen,
gidilmemesi gereken yola gittim.
Aradan zaman geçti,
bir daha hayatımda karşıma başka yol
ayrımları çıkmayacağını düşünürken
gidilmemesi gereken yolda, asıl gidilmeyen
yolu seçmek zorundaydım.
Evet, birçok zorunlu
seks işçisi arkadaşım var.
Yaptıkları işi kınamıyorum.
Hatta bugüne kadar bana destek oldukları
için de çok teşekkür ediyorum.
Ben oyuncu ve şarkıcı olmayı seçmiştim.
Başka başka engeller,
başka başka destekler,
başka başka aslında destek gibi
görünüp de destek olmayanlar.
Eh, sonucunu görüyorsunuz,
şu anda buradayım
ve konuşuyorum.
(Alkış)
O gidilmemesi gereken
yolla ilgili birçok anım var,
bir, iki tanesini paylaşmak
istiyorum sizinle.
O gidilmemesi gereken yolu seçtiğim zaman,
bizim çağımız internet çağı değildi.
Bir halk kütüphanesine gidip de
kendinize eşcinsellikle veya translıkla
alakalı bir kitap da isteyemiyordunuz.
Hemen bir arama motoruna girip aslında
ne olduğunuzu bilmiyordunuz.
Ben yıllarca kendimi X-Man
falan zannediyordum.
Gözümden falan ne zaman
ışın çıkaracağımı düşünüyordum
ama hiçbir zaman çıkaramadım.
Bunları atlattıktan sonra sizi
bilgilendirecek kimse olmadığı için
yıllarca kendimi gay zannettim.
Sonra tekrardan bir gidilmemesi
gereken yol buldum.
Haydi gaysin, saklarsın,
gizlice çalışırsın dedikleri zamanlarda
trans olduğumun farkına vardım ve
trans kimliğimi geliştirmeye çalıştım.
En ilginci de askerlik raporu alırkendi.
Evet, hemen hemen neredeyse yarı yarıya
değişim geçirmiş şekilde
askerlik raporu almak için
Yabancı İşler Şube Müdürlüğü
dedikleri bir yere gidiyorsunuz.
Ve size gerçekten tekrardan X-Man
olduğunuzu ispat eden bir rapor veriyorlar
çünkü raporda size FXD17'siniz diyorlar.
Böyle bir kodunuzla artık askerlik yapmak
zorunda olmadığınızı söylüyorlar
ama orada da çok sağ olsunlar,
teşekkür ederim, çok fazla uyarıyorlar.
Diyorlar ki işte,
"devlet memuru olamayacaksın,
çalışamayacaksın, edemeyeceksin" diye.
İlk oyunculuk teklifi bana geldiği zaman
sadece bu rapor için,
"devlet memurunu oynamak
istiyorum" demiştim.
(Kahkaha)
Eğer olamadıysam, oynarım en azından.
"Hayat bağları"nda bir hapishanede
gardiyan olmak istedim
onlar dediler ki
"olur mu ya senden gardiyan,
biz seni" dediler
"hapishane müdüriyesi yapalım".
Ya bu kadar baremi yüksek bir memur
olacağımı da bilmiyordum.
(Alkış)
Böylece bütün serüven başlamış oldu.
Gerçekten bir serüven.
Ben yola çıktığım zaman belki benden daha
önce şarkı söyleyen, oyunculuk yapan
birçok görünür veya
görünmez kişiler vardı.
Ama görünür oldukları hâlde LGBT ismini
anmayı tercih etmediler.
Ama ben, ömrüm yettikçe, görünür olduğum
sürece, konuştuğum sürece,
LGBT demeye devam edeceğim.
Her insan aynı şekilde --
(Alkış)
Teşekkür ederim.
Her insan aynı şekilde,
eğitim alana, yaşayana,
nefes alana kadar devam edeceğim.
Bu hayvanlar için de geçerli.
İnsanları bitiremedim, onlar için
pek bir şey yapamıyorum şu anda.
İnsan haklarıyla çalışmaya devam edeceğim.
Bu gidilemeyen yolda yedi tane dernek
kurduk arkadaşlarımla beraber,
insan hakları derneği.
Bütün ayrımcılığa karşıyız ve
ayrıcalığa da karşıyız.
Bugün bir kırmızı noktanın içerisinde
sizinle konuşuyor olmam bir ayrıcalık.
Ama bunu olumlu bir ayrıcalık olarak
görüyorum, o yüzden pozitif olduğu için.
Bir de bana kırmızı bir noktayla çıkıp da
konuşacaksın deseler inanmazdım,
çünkü eskiden kırmızı nokta gördüğümüzde
kanalı değiştirmemiz gerekiyordu.
(Kahkaha)
Benimle birlikte neler değişti derseniz,
aslında gerçekten bu kadar çok görünür
olmadığım sürece, yani sürelerde de
birçok şey değişmeye başlamıştı.
Gerçekten çok aç kaldım,
inanılmaz derecede de
paraya ihtiyacım oldu,
çok fazla ev kiramı ödeyemediğim için,
ev sahiplerinden helallik isteyip
ne olursunuz, üç aylık ödeyemedim deyip
ayrılmak zorunda kaldım.
Ama bu süreç içerisinde,
bana bir röportajda sordukları şeyin
cevabı aslında bu.
"Hayatınız boyunca" dediler
"seks işçiliği yaptınız mı?"
"Hayır, yapmadım" dedim.
Dediler ki bana "yani arada böyle
bir şeyler falan olmadı mı?"
"Yok hayır, olmadı ama seks işçiliğinden
gelen parayı yedim."
"Nasıl peki" dediler "yapmadan yediniz?"
"Çünkü zorunlu seks işçiliği
yapan arkadaşlarım
benim istediğim yolda başarılı olabilmem
adına paralarını bana gönderiyorlardı.
Kiramı ödüyorlardı,
ne bileyim işte, bilimum
ihtiyaçlarımı giderebiliyorlardı.
(Alkış)
Asıl şey olan, acı olan, gerçekten şu anda
sizin beni gördüğünüz hâliyle,
beni görebilecekleri zamanları
görememiş olan
ve öldürülmüş olan
seks işçisi arkadaşlarım var.
Eminim, üzülmenizi istemezlerdi
söylediklerimden,
sadece daha çok alkışlamanızı
isterlerdi ki sesleri duyulsun diye.
(Alkış)
Eminim bir yerlerde izliyorlardır.
Annemin çok ilginç bir anısı vardı.
Bandırma'da yaşardı annem,
bilmiyorum, bilenleriniz vardır,
orada da çok iyi bir iskenderci var,
genellikle ünlüler orada iskender yerler
ve duvarda fotoğrafları olur.
Bir gün biz yerken anneme demiştim ki
"anne, bir gün o duvarda benim de
fotoğrafım olacak"
annem de bana demişti ki
"ya, şimdi sen ye de
soğutma iskenderini, boşver"
(Kahkaha)
Bu gittiğimde, onun kabrinin
ziyaretine gittiğim zaman
orada iskender yedim ve adam gelip dedi ki
"ya duvara koymak için fotoğrafınızı
çekebilir miyiz?" diye sordu.
(Alkış)
Birçok şey değişti tabii.
Bir kere her şeyden önce
örgütlendikten sonra,
aslında örgütlü değildik,
nasıl örgütlendiğimizin de hikâyesi
çok enteresan ama
büyük bir ihtimalle buraya sığmayacaktır.
Neyse, daha on bir dakikam varmış
anlatabileyim diye.
Evet, biz Öztrans derneğini kurarken
hepimiz gözaltına alınmıştık,
gözaltında kurduk derneği.
Daha sonra birçok derneğin
kurucu üyesi oldum
ve birçoğunun gönüllüsü, aktivisti oldum.
Ama şimdi bütün LGBT derneklerinin
koruyucu meleğiyim hepsinin birden.
Onlar böyle bir ödül
vermek istediler bana,
bu da benim hayattaki
en değerli ödüllerden bir tanesi.
Derneklerin örgütlenmesi ve haklarımızın
olduğunu öğrenmemiz
bizi birazcık daha değiştirdi.
Örgütlenmek çok zor bir şey, yani,
gideceksiniz işte, aslında bir şeyler
yapmak istediğinizi anlatacaksınız.
Bunlar çok uzun ve yorucu şeyler
ama biz bıkmadık,
çalıştık, elimizden geleni yaptık.
Neler değişti derseniz,
benim tahminimce şu anda
oyunculuk yapmaya çalışan
yedi tane trans arkadaşım var.
Hepsi bir yerlerde oynamaya çalışır
ve çok başarılıları var,
hatta bunlardan bir tanesi de
tiyatro ödüllerinde en iyi kadın
oyuncu adayı olarak gösterildi.
Cerrahlar var,
yirmiyi geçkin eczacı var.
Tırnak içerisinde söylüyorum,
"normal" diye adlandırdığınız
birçok işte çalışan trans bireyler var.
Bunlar bizim mücadelemizle değil aslında
sizin kalbinizin gözü ne kadar açık olduğu
ve en sonda vicdanınızı
dinlediğiniz için gerçekleşti.
Ve siz birazcık daha bu konuşmadan
feyz alıp birazcık daha güçlü olursanız,
eminim ki, birçok şeyi değiştirebiliriz.
Düşünsenize, ben doğuştan omuzumda olan
o rütbelerin hepsini
bile isteye kendim söktüm
ve kadın olmaya karar verdim
ve iyi ki de kadın olmuşum.
İnanılmaz güzel bir şey.
(Alkış)
Tavsiye edermişim değil mi burada?
Evet, tavsiye edeceğim ama
kadın olmayı değil,
yani arada bence kadın gibi
düşünebilmeyi tavsiye ediyorum.
Birazcık gerçekten nerede, nasıl ve hangi
duygularla düşündüklerine baktığınız zaman
bütün dünya daha yeşil, bütün her yer
daha oksijen dolacak eminim buna.
Ayrıca da çok teşekkür ediyorum
bütün kadınlara burada oldukları için,
beylere de.
Sonra hayallerimi gerçekleştirmeme
izin verdiğiniz için,
beni görünür kıldığınız için.
Bu konuşmadan sonra göreceğiniz herhangi
bir trans bireye veya LGBT bireye
selam vereceğiniz için şimdiden
çok teşekkür ediyorum.
Büyük bir ihtimalle ya
video klibi izlerken,
ya İnstagram'dan takip ederken,
sosyal medyadan falan takip ederken,
hepsini zaten görüyorsunuz,
ne istediğimizi, ne olması gerektiğini
ve birçoğunu zaten
sizin de istediğinizi biliyorum.
Çok teşekkür ediyorum.
(Alkış)